did you approve of the laugh that he
does of you
oh I don't think I had a say in that one
if I got to be super oh you don't think
you had to say
that and that's probably why uh but I
will say
something cuz he used to talk like this
but now I think he and I sound more
alike than we ever have yeah so I don't
want to say you sound like that because
then if you sound like that that means I
sound like that too
that's true but I know I don't laugh
like
this my answer is no I did not approve
of that [__]
laugh can I tell you Pete we'll be
walking down the street and someone will
drive by and you'll just hear
oh [__] drive by just throwing out
insults out the [__]
window this dude I find his bone
bomb out by the trash cans where I empty
the trash he hid his bomb in a weird
like Hobbit
bag yeah like a hand knit like I
wouldn't notice his
handwoven 8th century Hobbit bag that
had a pan flute in it or some [__] but
it was it had a [__] bong this dude
thinks he's so smart didn't that happen
oh yeah it happened um can I uh can I
tell you something I've never told you
before just just on that note just on
that note wait wait wait wait wait this
is a live crowd do I want to hear
something I've never heard before does
everybody else want to hear it
okay you ready okay I don't think I'm
smart I know I'm smart and I know you're
stupid cuz you found the decoy
bomb wait wait wait wait that makes no
sense decoy bom what does that mean did
you ever even like look at the bomb
closely
no okay it didn't work it was broken it
was cracked in three different sides
there was something stuck in the
downstep you couldn't hit it if you
tried that was that rhymed by the way I
don't know if anybody got that that was
kind of [__] dror Su [__] up here um
but so here's the thing I started I did
that because it was around the time that
I figured out he started snooping he
found a vape in my room and I got
ridiculed tobacco VAP not ridiculed you
didn't get ridiculed you got [__]
laid into yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah is a
different granted which is fair but so I
knew you were snooping and so I decided
to plant something somewhere to where I
knew you would find it and then think
you found everything and not go look for
the actual bong and the actual stash
that was just sitting in my room for 10
years so I I don't think I'm super smart
but I know I'm smarter than
you so
thank you Madison that's my
time yeah yeah he's wearing shorts on a
date don't
about that is some
[__] yeah I've been waiting for a good
time to tell
you this is my this is my this my man
right here he's we're going to stick
together you know what I'm saying yeah
exactly that last line [__] fing killed
me I don't think I'm smart but I know
I'm smarter than you it's like that
really hit hard the dumbest thing he
ever tried to get past me was he came
home High one night and his eyes were
red and I asked him why and he goes oh
you know I'm allergic to cats I'm like
no you're
not he tried to tell me that the person
who's been with him every day of his
life that he was allergic to cats I'm
like you know we used to have a cat
don't don't you
remember second dumbest thing the
dumbest thing he ever said to me he
tried to get a lie past
me so he took the car his car to school
in the morning like you know 7:00 a.m.
and the school was like4 mile from our
house and the school calls me in the
morning it was like Jacob's late and it
was like easily an hour after school was
supposed to start I go okay they're like
what do you want to do I go I'll talk to
him and get home they're like
okay so he walks in the door and I go
hey man and he goes yeah I go school
call said you were late getting to
school he's like yeah I was I go what
happened he goes I got stuck behind a
parade a [__]
parade I said on a Tuesday morning at
a.m. in front of the school he goes yeah
I thought it was pretty weird
too and then I said to him I go so
everybody at school was late he goes no
I was the last card to make
it and he goes I watched all the floats
he even went floats I'm like you thought
I go what parade was it he was like I
don't know they seem to be celebrating
everything [__] parade you raise your
hand I will definitely call on you yeah
my man as your dad caught you jacking
off are you talking to me or him
that's actually a good question follow
question do do you do
you well okay hold on before anybody
answers that I think both of us are
going to have a different answer I think
I'm going to say no because I don't
think I've ever been caught but I think
you might have an answer of you might
have walked in on it and I didn't see
you here's what's even worse yeah that's
what's going to happen I knew that was
going to be the answer by the way like
he was going to say yes and I was going
to say when it wasn't it wasn't me it
wasn't me it was your
mom she walked into the bedroom ghost
white shut the door and she goes I'm
never going in his room
again and right away I was like oh he
was jerking off huh she was like how'd
you know I'm like that's the only thing
that would have listen that yeah well
that's a bummer well yeah but you know
what's equally a bummer he and I were
doing a live stream oh yeah live stream
yeah thousands of people and he goes did
I ever tell you when I walked in on you
and Mom I was like
what and I said to him I go dude how old
are you I thinking he was going to say I
was like seven how old did you say you
were
18 it's my senior year of high school
just looking for the car keys godamn it
just looking for the [__] car keys
you know where they weren't not F in my
[__] wait unfortunately in your jeans
um all right but
but so I've never caught him jerking off
uh but my wife has and um sorry
yeah I'm not that's funny as [__] I like
it how about this one how about this one
what does that say I'm 23 I'm 21 and my
parents still like acting like I'm a kid
what do I tell them oh okay why don't
you go first and then I'll
go I mean I guess it all depends if he
if they still live at the house or not
it's kind of you know what I'm saying if
you live at the house you're treated
like a kid you move out that may not
change least you be in your own
place tell them the video you sent me
your first morning when you woke up in
your first apartment oh okay yeah so I
still had boxes and [__] everywhere I
didn't do anything the first night I put
together my bed so I had a place to
sleep after I got super high that night
to celebrate that I moved out other than
that I just saved everything for you
know the next week I woke up the next
morning and in my Fringe I had nothing I
had a case of beer and in my cabinet I
had a box of cereal so there's only one
obvious thing to do there right so I you
know pulled my phone out and I took a
video of me pouring beer into my cereal
and eating it and then taking a bong RP
and then I that was the first thing I S
to him yeah you remember what I said you
remember what you said you took a bite
you took the bong rip you blew it out
and you went in my own place
[__] I was pretty excited yo man I
would say to that person and I don't
know you and I don't know your situation
but you don't want to be treated like a
kid stop acting like a [__]
kid yo man I know a lot of people are
like I don't want to be treated like a
kid but but I live in my parents place
well then guess the [__] what y if your
parents still fold your socks you got to
listen to their dumbass rules that's the
only deal yeah you want to go get your I
we when he he dropped out of college and
I was fine with that man you get to make
your own decisions if you're 18 but he
was like I'm just going to stay here at
the house I was like no you're
not grown people who are in the
workplace don't live at my [__] house
and I go you got three months and then
we'll help you find a place but you got
to get out of here and I go I think
it'll be remember this I
go I go I go listen I give him the whole
speech I think it'll be good for you man
it'll be good for your confidence it'll
be good for you figuring out how do you
you you need to do things on your own
and you want to make a grown-up decision
you got to have make grownup choices man
and you have to grown up things will
happen but I think it'll be good for
your confidence and I think it'll be
good for you in the long run and he
looks at me and he
goes agree to
disagree still trying to save some money
man and I was like I don't know what the
[__] that means but you're still moving
out so does that ever happen to you
where you guys you feel good about
yourselves you're like I feel pretty
good and then your grown human walks by
and you're like is that my grown human
that happens to me all the time man you
know I when when when we left Los we
don't live in Los Angeles anymore and
when we left there Jacob stayed in LA
and um I went to visit him and he goes
you can you can hang out at my apartment
when I'm at
work I said okay and I went to visit his
apartment and I called him from his
apartment when he was at work and I go
hey man he goes hey I said I just want
you to know it's payback
time so I'm going to jerk off in your
bathroom and steal your
weed and he said don't do
that I said too late one down and I'm
looking for the
weed don't use that towel on your face
but here's the
deal we did a podcast a couple weeks ago
where we had talked about how I I kind
of was a scapegoat for two of my friends
uh all three of us lived on the same
street through High School uh so we were
all neighbors but their parents were not
as as cool as mine so I I knew that I
could be the scapegoat for you know if
we they ever got caught smoking weed I'd
be like just don't say it was your idea
blame it on me great one of their parent
a set of parents came over to the house
yeah to give me a
talk and I was like listen dude I'm not
going to I'm not going to rat you out
I'm not going to rat them out but in
solidarity with you for this meeting I'm
going to be high as
[__] yeah so I got super high and just
dipped Ruffles into ranch dip the whole
meeting it's a power move this one is my
absolute favorite story about my
youngest son and um so here's a couple
things you need to know about him going
in first of all my youngest son here's
what I love the most about him no matter
where he
is that's the best place he's ever
been yo that dude does not know how to
have a bad time he look and it's a I
envy that attitude does and by the way
look his energy is crazy I could put him
down at any of your tables he could talk
to any of you for an hour and you'd be
like I know this dude for a decade like
it's crazy that kind of I don't even
know if you call it skill but it's it's
born you know he is also the dumbest of
my three
kids
now he's not dumb I'm not saying he's
dumb but who has multiple kids in here
anybody have multiple kids hey look if
you got multiple kids you've got a dumb
one too that's all I'm saying they may
not be stupid but there's a stupidest
one out of all of them that's the dumb
one and I'm going to tell you something
else if you got more than one kid you
have had this conversation with your
partner in the
bedroom what the [__] are we going to do
with the dumb
one we going to let him walk out there
by himself he's so [__] stupid you
know what I
mean here's my favorite story about my
son so uh a long time ago long time ago
um when I uh was a single guy I used to
take the kids down to Mexico and um on
day trips and because Mexico I lived in
Southern California it was cheap you can
go down there $50 it's a new culture you
know what I mean it's a new country and
it's super cool adventure you know so
but you couldn't go until you were
seven so by the time Jakey turned seven
I was married and but he was like I want
to go to Mexico and I said cool and he
was guys driving down to Mexico he was
pumped the whole way right just [__]
pointing things out he's like is that
Mexico I'm like no that's Home Depot
[Music]
um but we're driving down there we get
to Mexico we're there for about an hour
and he turns to me he goes ha
dad I L by the way he has always stood
like Forest Gump I have no idea why this
dude has always he used to he was a
great baseball player he'd hit a double
and slide into second and he'd pop up
like
this and I
was I was always like great hit buddy
put your hands down great
hit not bad you
know so we're there for an hour and he
goes H dad I love
Mexico everybody here is so smart and I
was
like
what makes you say that man he goes H
they all know how to speak
Spanish and I was like oh come here you
dumb [__]
okay Daddy's going to take care of you
for as long as he has to I
guess you're going to live with me till
you're 40 aren't you
buddy we were there for another hour and
this dude decides he can speak Spanish
cuz to him it sounds like
[Applause]
this and I go hey man hey
hey I said do not speak the
Spanish and he goes no I know how to
speak it I go no you don't no I
don't so we walk around for a while we
end up going to a restaurant you know
and we sit out and the dude drops two
menus and in eng English he says to me
what can I get you to drink I said I
would love a medell please he said
absolutely and in English he says to my
son what can I get you to drink young
man my son's looking at the menu and
he's
[Music]
like
and he
goes Mexican Coke I go what are you
saying to this to and he walks away I go
Jakey what' I tell you man do not speak
the Spanish and he goes no I know how to
talk it I go no you don't and he got
really cocky he
goes he took my
order I was like you said the word Coke
bro you know you know what I
mean I said listen man I know you don't
understand this and I don't I know you
don't mean to but you're insulting this
man's culture and his Heritage and his
language and you're doing it right to
his face and I'm telling you right now
that's not okay so under no circumstance
are you to speak the Spanish ever again
do you understand me and he goes yes Dad
so we finish up our food
right and uh because I tell him not to
speak the Spanish he's silken and he's
like I just want to go home I said all
right he goes can I lay down in the back
seat and go to sleep and I was like
sure so we're driving up to the
border and uh the border patrol guy he
says to me he goes uh can I see your ID
and I said yeah and he
goes great he said you get a birth
certificate for the
kid I said no why do I need a birth
certificate for my kid and he said well
I got to make sure every child that
leaves Mexico is a Mexican how do I know
he's not Mexican and I was
like so I said
Jacob speak the
[Applause]
Spanish this dude's head popped up from
the back seat
[Music]
like and the guy just looked at me and
he at him and he was like have a great
day we're driving out of Mexico right 15
minutes no we neither one of us said
anything and he's just looking out the
back window and it's rolled down he's
got the wind blowing in his face and I
just hear him Mumble under his
breath I told you I know how to speak
Spanish [__] [__]
dick question was what was the thing
that truly pissed you off that your dad
did to you to encourage you to fight him
he took all my underwear out replaced it
with panties and they all had a day of
the week on them right so Monday Monday
through Sunday right I used to tell him
put your Mondays on dude come on out
here he was like [__]
you the thing that oh infuriates me or
infuriated me the most he used to put a
gloss of Vaseline in each one of my
hoodie Pockets my jacket pockets
sometimes my pants Pockets so I put
everything on it me like all right I'm
ready to go and I put my hand in my
pocket and it was
just yo yo that pissed me off yo it's 7
in the morning and I'm going to school
I'm already not the happiest person in
the world and sticking my hand in
petroleum jelly at 7:15 in the morning
doesn't make me feel a lot better you
know I don't have a question I just want
to say thank you for making me feel less
ashamed that I have more accidents than
like did he just call me an
[Applause]
accident I'm a little confused here
ladies and
gentlemen I am not going to lie I don't
know if that was directed at me or not
um
I sure [__] hope not
man oh I can't wait to tell your brother
and sister
[Laughter]
that you're going to have a new nickname
around the house I
think